bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 26 janvier tremblement de terre au
centre ouest de la colombie la nuit
dernière un premier bilan officieux fait
état de plus de mille morts bilan santé
alarmant pour les cyclistes français une
enquête sur le dopage révèle de graves
perturbations biologique parmi les
coureurs la parité homme femme n'est pas
du goût des sénateurs il conteste
l'inscription dans la constitution du
principe d'égal accès des femmes et des
hommes aux mandats électoraux et
fonctions électives les états unis
poursuivent le bombardement de la
défense anti aérienne irakienne la
france se déclare préoccupé par cette
forme de guerre sans nom
tennis amélie mauresmo accède aux demi
finales du tournoi d'australie elle se
repose et la numéro un mondiale lindsay
d'avesnes fois c'est au centre ouest de
la colombie que se trouve la ville
d'armenia c'est là que les effets du
séisme de la nuit dernière se sont fait
sentir le plus violemment
pour cette seule ville d'armenia les
sauveteurs estiment qu'il durerait au
moins 1000 morts déjà un mouvement
d'elles internationale s'organise pour
aider les secours et les victimes
colombienne commentaire j de mariner
c'est au lever du jour que l'ampleur du
désastre s'est révélée la ville
d'arminia et détruites dans des
proportions encore difficile à estimer
certains quartiers n'existe plus
dans une telle situation est très grand
très difficile ce quartier est
pratiquement détruit à 90%
un séisme de 6 degrés sur l'échelle de
richter a surpris les trois cent mille
habitants plaine où la première secousse
a duré 60 secondes quand j'ai senti la
première secousse mais si j'avais une
fille de deux ans sur les genoux
j'ai voulu aller vers la sortie mais je
n'ai pas eu le temps
c'est allé trop vite les murs se sont
écroulés et la terre a continué à
trembler quatorze fois les survivants
s'improvise sauveteurs et ce qui peut
permettre de dégager les décombres est
mise à contribution
ça montre un wagon à soissons est en
train de travailler à soulever des
plaques de béton on a déjà trouvé
plusieurs cadavres et des survivants
mille cadavres déjà un bilan qui
concerne à ce vil d'arminia mais c'est
toute une région qui a été frappé
d'autres villes d'autres villages et sur
le sort de leur habitat actuellement on
ne sait rien après le tour de france
cycliste un suivi médical avait été
décidée consistant à surveiller
périodiquement le métabolisme des
coureurs et à détecter une éventuelle
prise de produits dopants
les premiers résultats de ce suivi
révèle que la moitié du peloton cycliste
français a usé de substances dangereuses
pour la santé
explication benoît thevenet 200 coureurs
professionnels ou amateurs de haut
niveau contrôler quatre fois par an
c'est ce qu'a décidé le ministère de la
jeunesse et des sports à l'automne
dernier et les premiers résultats sont
éloquents dans 90 % des cas le taux de
fer dans le sang et 5 à 20 fois
supérieur à la normale on sait par
ailleurs que le p o et le fer font bon
ménage
le pays a pour fonction d'augmenter le
nombre de globules rouges et donc le
volume d'oxygène transportés dans les
muscles
mais la fabrication de ces globules
rouges nécessite du fer et sportif qui
se dopent le pays prenne donc dû faire
supplémentaires une surdose qui n'est
pas sans danger
représente un risque évidemment puisque
je te caches du fer seraient
principalement dans le foie et ceci à
long terme fait le lit de la cirrhose
elle même faisant le lit du cancer du
foie du côté de la fédération française
de cyclisme qui a approuvé la mise en
place de ce suivi médical après le tour
de france 98 on ne s'attendait peut-être
pas à des résultats aussi probants
évidemment on est surpris par l'ampleur
du phénomène et nous voulons le traité
sur le plan de la santé cela étant
lorsqu'on parle de deux morts je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut quand même être
prudent
le taux de fer dans le sang aussi élevée
soit il ne constitue pas une preuve de
dopage le contrôle des coureurs tels
qu'il est effectuée par l'unité mobile
ne sert qu'à prévenir d'éventuels ennuis
de santé
là c'est vraiment le rôle des médecins
de prendre une décision en conscience
par rapport à la situation de tel ou tel
sportif on est dans le domaine de la
prévention ensuite bon y'a les contrôles
qu'elle contrôle positif ya les
sanctions sportives et la celle de voir
la fédération de cyclistes ont ainsi été
mis en arrêt maladie
un signe pour le peloton où les anges
gardiens le savent la tentation n'est
jamais très loin
et pour ajouter à ce constat de santé
inquiétant voici un témoignage
individuel celui d'un ancien coureur
professionnel entre 1993 et 1996
jean-christophe currit tu il raconte des
pratiques de dopage ordinaire reportage
françois privat philippe ritaine le
dopage
jean-christophe currit l'a connu à 29
ans il n'est plus coureur cycliste
professionnel manque de performance en
1996 après deux saisons au sein de la
formation gagnent son contrat n'est pas
renouvelé à l'époque roger legeay le
directeur sportif de l'équipe ne veut
surtout pas entendre parler de dopage
mais il faut des résultats
c'est un peu à peu la politique un peu
la politique de l'autruche et et
débrouille toi et fais ce que tu peux
faire ce que tu veux et par contre on
veut pas entendre parler mais ramène
toujours des points enfin et c'est là
que le danger risque
d'avoir lieu c'est que le coureur
prennent n'importe quel produit
n'importe comment et sans savoir quel
effet alors en le premier son corps
équipiers de lemon et boardman
jean-christophe faire sa place chez les
pros et disputer le tour de france en
1994 quelques semaines avant le départ
de la grande boucle au cours du tour de
suisse et s'injectent des corticoïdes
pour réaliser une belle étape
un coup on prend une équipe gagnent en
croire une autre équipe mène une ampoule
de corticoïdes assez puissant et me dit
de tout faire la veille la veille au
soir des belles étapes que je ce que je
fais est le lendemain je me suis
retrouvé à pied donc j'en ai déduit que
j'allais être j'avais trophée frank j
mais jamais je n'aurais pas dû faire
toutes les ampoules
donc je lui maillot fallait que tu
fasses qu'un car l'avant dernier jour du
tour de suisse je sais qu nettement à
pied donc c'est pas comme ça que c'est
pas du dopage par mois c'est du mauvais
de pages pour moi c'est là que c'est là
je dis que lepage suivi à l'intérieur de
l'équipe est beaucoup mieux que le
dopage sauvage comme j'ai pu le
connaître au sein et kim gagnent
aujourd'hui
jean-christophe currit souhaitent
s'investir dans la prévention et
rencontrer de jeunes cyclistes pour
éviter qu'à l'aube de leur carrière ils
ne commettent les mêmes erreurs que lui
au sénat où la proportion de femmes
élues n'atteint pas les 6%
le projet de révision de la constitution
permettant une loi ouvrant un égal accès
des femmes et des hommes aux mandats
électoraux et fonctions électives n'est
pas du goût de la majorité de droite
cette résistance à un texte pourtant
conjointement voulu par l'elysée et
matignon a suscité une manifestation
devant le palais du luxembourg la
ministre de la justice a même quitté le
débat pour aller manifester
reportage laurent hakim bernard connor
deux ministres sous les banderoles
en plein débat sur la parité au sénat
elisabeth guigou et nicole péry ont
voulu elle aussi dénoncé à leur manière
le blocage du texte par les élus du
palais du luxembourg
elles ont donc rejoint un moment la
manifestation d'une centaine de
militantes féministes
la ministre de la justice souhaite que
le dernier verrou saute enfin pour
permettre cette égalité pour que nous
puissions pour que le législateur puisse
prendre des mesures concrètes dans les
lois pour favoriser l'accès des femmes
aux mandats et aux fonctions électives
il faut qu'on arrive à changer les lois
et pour lever le verrou constitutionnel
mais aujourd'hui au sénat les femmes
étaient plutôt dans le public pour
entendre des hommes à la tribune parler
de la parité
le sénat a fait de la résistance ils
remettent en cause le texte de
l'assemblée nationale il veut laisser
l'initiative de cette parité aux partis
politiques ils verraient dans 20 ans il
y aura cette fois ci peut être des
hommes qui demanderont et manifesteront
dans la rue pour exiger des quotas
faveur des hommes devront pas cela par
pitié le doute a même gagné les rangs de
la gauche ou la thèse d'elisabeth
badinter relayée dans l'hémicycle par
son mari sénateur des hauts-de-seine
donne également la préférence à une
démarche volontariste pas de dissension
dit on au ps
mais plutôt un débat philosophique les
résistances du sénat risque de retarder
la révision constitutionnelle et la
réunion du congrès envisagent et le 8
mars prochain dans l'autre enceintes
parlementaires au palais bourbon lors
des questions d'actualité le premier
ministre cet après midi à très sèchement
montré son agacement devant la
multiplication des questions de
l'opposition sur les problèmes
d'insécurité
voyez le reportage de j'ai vite imbert
et jean-françois renou l'opposition on
est convaincu lui dans le débat sur la
sécurité il y a aujourd'hui un malaise
au sein du gouvernement entre jean
pierre chevènement elisabeth guigou
entre la ligne dure privilégiant la
répression et une politique plus
équilibrée alors l'opposition attaque et
elle le fait avec méthode aux principes
notre pays se transforme peu à peu en
zone de non droit
il ne se passe pas de jour sans que
l'actualité ne nous révèle une poussée
de la délinquance dans le pays
ce que les français attendent c'est
d'autre chose que des zizanies au sein
même de votre gouvernement sur son bon
lionel jospin compte le nombre de fois
où son gouvernement est interpellé sur
la sécurité à la 6e il décide lui même
de répondre à l'opposition est ce que il
n'y a plus maintenant dans notre pays
d'autres problèmes qui méritent d'être
débattues discutées dans la
représentation nationale et devant les
français croyez vous que cette approche
exclusive d'un problème nourrissent en
votre faveur
un mouvement de compréhension et d'appui
ne pensez vous pas plutôt que vous aller
nourrir les forces d'extrême droit par
ce discours à votre dépend la riposte
est classique mais la droite est piqué
au vif
sortie de l'hémicycle elle fait donner
de la voix j'espère pareil comme un
matador
qui dit je vais tuer je vais je vais
lutter il ne fait rien il n'y avait qu'à
voir la tête de monsieur chevènement
pour voir qu'il ya un profond désaccord
quoi qu'en dise le premier ministre
entre la position du premier ministre et
du garde des sceaux et celle du ministre
de l'intérieur
les mesures qui sortiront du conseil de
sécurité intérieure demain à matignon
sont particulièrement attendus ces
questions de sécurité au culte
aujourd'hui presque tout l'espace du
débat politique
le premier ministre affirme que son
équipe gouvernement table sur ces
problèmes de sécurité intérieure a une
vision globale sur la nécessité d'agir
aussi bien en matière de prévention que
dans le domaine de la répression
et pourtant son ministre de l'intérieur
jean pierre chevènement continue
d'adresser des pics à sa collègue de la
justice
aujourd'hui encore gérard leclerc il
estimait que les procédures de la
justice ne répondait pas aux problèmes
réels alors chevènement ça veut dire
cactus dans la majorité était en tout
cas jean pierre chevènement a les
défauts de ses qualités c'est un homme
d'état plusieurs féministes mais qui
elle démissionner on s'en souvient deux
fois avec fracas c'est un vrai politique
aux convictions affirmées mais jusqu'à
la polémique et voir les dérapages
et puis c'est un homme d'ordre qui a
largement contribué à convertir la
gauche aux questions de sécurité mais
quitte à flirter selon certains avec le
sécuritaire c'est que jean pierre
chevènement qui sort sur d'excellents
sondages force son talent dans la
provocation est fait du même coup
tanguay le gouvernement et la majorité
plurielle
depuis le miracle républicain de sa
guérison
il ne cesse d'en rajouter dans le
discours martial contre les petits caïds
et les sauvageons tarn terme qui heurte
bien sûr la bonne conscience de la
gauche dans les empiètements sur les
prérogatives de la ministre de la
justice enfin dans les attaques contre
daniel cohn bendit gracieusement
qualifiée d'anarcho mercantiliste ou
simplement d'allemands veut dire que les
verts noël mamère ou daniel cohn bendit
ont répliqué à eux aussi sur un ton
assez vif absolument s qui obligeait le
parti socialiste a lancé une sorte de
halte au feu contre les agressions les
mots blessants
ça n'a pas suffi lionel jospin a dû lui
aussi en appeler un débat maîtrisé tout
en adoptant sur la question de la
sécurité la position d'arbitré qu'il
affectionne sensiblement plus favorable
tout de même au ministre de la justice
alors les esprits vont-ils se calmer
c'est ce que pense matignon qui souligne
qu'après tout avec ces divergences
affichées la gauche occupe tout l'espace
du débat face une droite souvent absente
mais s'il en était autrement
deux pièces maîtresses de lionel jospin
jean-pierre chevènement pourrait bien
devenir son talon d'achille
la merci les magistrats de la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel de
versailles ont décidé de supprimer
certains chefs de mise en examen contre
monsieur alain juppé dans la sphère des
emplois fictifs de membres du rpr à la
mairie de paris
mais l'ancien premier ministre voit
toujours reproché trois délits dont
celui d'abus de confiance commentaires
olivier caroff avec frédéric de la rue
les avocats d'alain juppé avait demandé
l'annulation de toutes les enquêtes sur
les emplois fictifs du rpr
espoir déçu la chambre d'accusation de
versailles mais annulé qu'une quinzaine
de pièces mais pour les défenseurs de
l'ancien premier ministre il ya tout de
même quelques raisons de se réjouir ces
annulations sont largement supérieures à
celle qu'avait demandé l'avocat général
qui réclamait que l'on enlève trois
lignes la chambre d'accusation par cette
annulation nombreuse a montré que la
procédure n'avait pas été menée
conformément partie au code de procédure
pénale victoire psychologique plus que
judiciaire car alain juppé reste au
coeur du dossier
voici la liste des délits dont il était
soupçonné en août dernier lors de sa
mise en examen aujourd'hui
les juges de versailles annuler la
notion de détournement de fonds publics
et considère que s'il y a un but
confiance il ne serait être aggravée par
les fonctions qu'occupait alors alain
juppé entre 88 et 95
alain juppé était en effet à la fois
secrétaire général du rpr et adjoint aux
finances de la ville de pâtes
pouvait-il donc ignorer que la mairie
paient les salaires de certains
permanents du parti at il participé à ce
système ces questions le juge des murs
chargés de l'enquète aimerait bien lui
poser
mais les avocats d'alain juppé
envisagent maintenant de se pourvoir en
cassation
le juge risque donc d'attendre plusieurs
mois avant de pouvoir interroger son
principal suspect le tribunal de grande
instance de paris a donné raison à
bernard tapie qui avait engagé un procès
en diffamation contre l'ancien
conseiller de jean marie le pen lorrain
de saint-affrique ce dernier affirmait
que monsieur le pen et tapie avait
négocié en 88 et 93 leur élection dans
les bouches du rhône bernard tapie a
gagné en première instance mais lorrain
de saint-affrique fait appel les puits
réquisitions à grasse devant le tribunal
correctionnel
le procureur a demandé 30 mois de prison
avec sursis et 47,5 millions de francs
d'amendé
contre le promoteur parisien christian
pellerin accusés d'infractions aux
règles de l'urbanisme en irak la défense
anti-aérienne de saddam hussein est
considéré comme une cible légitime par
les militaires américains les états unis
pour suivre des bombardements et des
tirs de missiles sur territoire irakien
ces nouveaux raids américains provoque
ce que l'on appelle en termes
diplomatiques
la préoccupation des autorités
françaises d'autant plus que les actions
militaires américaines ont été peu près
six parfois explications richard binet
c'était l'un des quartiers les plus
populaires de la banlieue sud de
bassorah al-joumhouriya ou plutôt ce
qu'il en reste
il était 10 heures les enfants jouaient
dans la rue lorsque le premier missile
américain s'est abattue
il est arrivé de cette direction dans la
maison il y avait mon neveu il a été tué
bah des autres membres de la famille ont
été blessés et une fois encore le
décompte macabre des victimes onze morts
59 blessés tous civils des femmes des
enfants des vieillards qui ne
comprennent pas pourquoi ils ont été la
cible des chasseurs américains
mon fils allait tout simplement à
l'école l'avion est arrivé a tiré et l'a
blessé
le pentagone a d'abord affirmé que ses
avions n'avait fait que répondre à une
provocation de l'adc à irakienne pour
ensuite reconnaître qu'un ou plusieurs
missiles auraient pu s'égarer sur des
quartiers résidentiels
nous regrettons profondément si c'est le
cas la mort de civils
mais ces échanges de feu ont été
directement initiée par saddam hussein a
dû mourir à n'était pas un site
stratégique encore moins un enjeu
militaire mais lorsqu une superpuissance
se trompent
l'erreur de trajectoire du tout
simplement des hommes des femmes et des
enfants
à washington les procureurs au procès en
destitution de bill clinton au sénat ont
décidé de convoquer trois témoins donc
monica levinsky bien sûr les sénateurs
se décideront demain
en jordanie le roi désigné son fils aîné
comme héritier du trône et ainsi
destituer son frère après l'avoir
violemment critiqué et après avoir fait
prêter serment son fils âgé de 36 ans le
roi hussein de jordanie a repris l'avion
pour les états unis afin d'y être de
nouveau hospitalisé on sait que le roi
est atteint d'un cancer des ganglions
lymphatiques correspondance d'isabelle
steiss à l'occasion du départ du roi
hussein ce matin pour les états unis
les deux frères se sont embrassés ainsi
il exige le protocole fraternité de
façade car la rupture est brutale entre
le prince hassan et le souverain
hachémite
c'est désormais le fils aîné du roi le
prince abdallah qui assure la régence
il a prêté serment ce matin au palais le
roi donc remercier son frère après 34
ans de régence
ils lui reprochent de se comporter en
monarque au moment où lui même lutte
contre la maladie
il y a une semaine à peine il affichait
pourtant l'image d'une famille unie le
roi hussein était de retour au pays
complètement guérie disette on alors et
la foule venue l'accueillir ne se
doutait pas d un tri qui agitaient déjà
le palais abus de pouvoir règlement de
comptes jalousie l'euro accuse
aujourd'hui son frère d'avoir nommé en
son absence des proches à des postes
clés notamment dans l'armée ingérence
dans les affaires militaires et
blessures personnelles
le prince hassan n'ayant jamais caché
son antipathie envers la quatrième
épouse du souverain la reine yu
au moment où la santé du roi semble se
dégrader le prince abdallah fils d'une
précédente union devient donc l'héritier
du trône
à 37 ans on ne lui connaît pas
d'ambition politique ce militaire de
carrière à la tête des forces spéciales
jordaniennes est assuré de la fidélité
de l'armée
un atout majeur pour la stabilité du
royaume au delà des intrigues de palais
l'avenir du royaume hachémite est
observé avec beaucoup d'attention par
ses voisins ayant des frontières
communes avec israël la syrie et l'irak
et une population à majorité
palestinienne
le petit royaume de jordanie en est pas
moins stratégique tout problème de
transition créé un nouveau déséquilibre
dans la région en allemagne suite du
débat sur les conditions de l'abandon de
l'énergie nucléaire promis lors de la
campagne it orale par les verts
aujourd'hui associé au pouvoir avec les
sociaux démocrates
le ministre allemand de l'environnement
monsieur treating réagi de manière
nuancée après les premières négociations
avec les industriels et l'on évoque des
problèmes de droit international pour
expliquer aussi le report à une date
précise du débat sur le projet de loi
prévoyant donc la fin du nucléaire
allemand
reportage de notre correspondant olivier
lerner une route semée d'embûches pour
le chancelier allemand
il a d'abord devant lui l'expression du
mécontentement des militants
antinucléaires
ils attendaient la fermeture des
centrales et l'arrêt du retraitement des
déchets cette année cela ne se fera pas
si vite
la verdure pour cadre des négociations
mais en toile de fond les menaces des
français et des britanniques pour les
indemnisations les avertissements des
industriels et la pression des verts
gare à chaud leur devait bien céder
devant quelqu'un il confirme ce soir
qu'il accède à une exigence capitale des
exploitants des 19 centrales du pays
le retraitement des déchets nucléaires
allemands à l'étranger dit-il se
poursuivra après l'an 2000 et plus
aucune date n'est fixée et l'arrêt des
centrales
le chancelier n'en parle même pas pour
les industriels c'est une grande
victoire inespérée sans doute pas
obtenir un tel résultat que cheffesse
fait ce que je ne sommes pas d'accord
pour abandonner le nucléaire
nous considérons que c'est une très
grande faute historique mais nous sommes
sûrs gun chritine le ministre verte de
l'environnement est désavoué rédacteurs
du texte de loi
il devra revoir sa copie dépité il nous
déclare qu avec un peu d'effort on
aurait pu trouver de meilleures
solutions à berlin l'immeuble des verts
est occupé par des militants de base
mais ici on reste optimiste je pense que
on est toujours sur le bon chemin et on
est condamné à trouver une solution
on est là pour surmonter les obstacles
pas pour pour faire faillite de vente
chez les verts ici en réunion les
esprits se sont un peu calmés en
l'espace de 24 heures l'abandon du
nucléaire sera donc consensuel
progressif et ordonnée les écologistes
ne sont plus à deux mois
hier soir en seine saint denis à pantin
un homme de 28 ans armé d'un fusil à
pompe a été tué par un policier qui
tentait de l'interpeller
la thèse de la légitime défense pourrait
être confirmée par l'enquêté de
l'inspection générale des services les
faits se sont déroulés dans la cité des
courtillières à pantin sans témoin
direct reportages patrick fandio
jean-louis bouchehr et luc bachofen
aucune trace aucun indice aucune gerbe
de fleurs sur les lieux du drame à
l'entrée de cet immeuble à quelques
mètres de là cela discrète surveillance
de dizaines de policiers rappellent la
course poursuite mortelle de l'année il
est 19 heures d'hier soir un groupe de
jeunes s'enfuient à l'arrivée d'une
patrouille
d'après les policiers l'un d'eux se
retourne et braqué un fusil à pompe sur
un gardien de la paix celui ci tire une
première fois sans l'atteindre plus une
seconde fois le jeune homme s'écroule
comprends pas pourquoi ils ont tiré sur
lui présent pas tirer sur quelqu'un dans
ce cas la crise je sais pas moi c'est
sur lui qu'ils ont tiré aulas le
procureur a lu le rapport d'autopsié les
récits des policiers pour lui pas de
doute il ya légitime défense l'un des
policiers présents qui lui-même
poursuivaient l'autre individu l'a
entendu un certain moment son collègue
celui qui devait être l'auteur du coup
de feu faire des sommations
alla vers celle qui poursuivait de jeter
son arme à plusieurs reprises ce qui
fait que cet officier radio police a
donc après avoir entendu distinctement
c'est sa nation de te jeter larmes a
évidemment considérer que son collègue
se trouve être en danger
déjà interpellé plusieurs fois par la
police le jeune homme n'habitait plus le
quartier depuis quelques années ce qui
expliquerai d'après certains habitants
le calme qui régnait dont la cité la
nuit dernière à vincennes dans le val de
marne l'institut aubert a rouvert ses
portes cet institut avait été fermée
officiellement pour raisons de sécurité
par la mairie de vincennes le maire de
la ville soupçonnant un enseignement de
l'église de scientologie dans cette
école privée
la directrice de cette école a mais
effectivement faire partie de l'église
de scientologie comme plusieurs membres
du conseil d'administration
reportage de joël bruandet et joseph
belgique sur la façade de l'institut
aubert la direction affiche fièrement
l'arrêté municipal autorisant la
réouverture
pour autant les parents d'élèves sont
loin d'être aussi fier
la fermeture aura duré deux mois deux
mois pendant lesquels une quinzaine
d'enfants sur 60 ont quitté
l'établissement en décembre dernier
alertés par des parents inquiet le maire
ferme l'école officiellement pour des
raisons de sécurité en fait la mairie
s'inquiète surtout de la nature de
l'enseignement dispensé à l'institut
aubert sa directrice qui nous avait
reçus ne cachait pas son appartenance à
la scientologie
je vois pas pourquoi ennuis étiquette
scientologie sur l'école partenaire
directrice ne cache pas c'est c'est
l'appartenance à l'église je ne les
cache pas que je suis pas non plus en
train de l'écrire tous les jours ici
dans l'école
pourtant les méthodes pédagogiques
employé ici sont directement inspirés de
la scientologie
à commencer par ce manuel signé ron
hubbard demi pour apprendre le fondateur
de la scientologie
l'une des sectes les plus dangereuses
qui existent dans le pays profite de la
loi comme elle est aujourd'hui pour en
fin de compte s'acharner sur les enfants
pourront en faire ensuite des adeptes de
la scientologie
mais la loi change depuis un mois en
effet l'éducation nationale peut
contrôler les établissements hors
contrat comme l'institut aubert ségolène
royal demande aujourd'hui aux recteurs
et aux inspecteurs d'académie de
commencer les contrôles prévus par la
loi
nous prendrons toutes les mesures de
faire peut-être nécessaire mais une fois
les faits établis pour l'instant on est
sur du déclaratif
rien n'est fait la bri si le contrôle
devait révéler que les enfants ne
reçoivent pas l'instruction à laquelle
ils ont droit
les sanctions peuvent aller jusqu'à la
fermeture définitive de l'établissement
manifestation cet après midi à paris de
la sorbonne à l'hôtel matignon pour
protester contre la réforme des lycées
pour réclamer la démission de claude
allègre
il y avait effectivement un collectif
constitué contre le ministre de
l'éducation
plusieurs syndicats dont le snes
faisaient également partie du cortège
rassemblant plusieurs milliers de
personnes selon les organisateurs en
moselle à moyeuvre grande des risques
d'affaissement miniers ont été jugés
suffisamment sérieux par la préfecture
pour provoquer l'évacuation de 35
familles d'une cité ouvrière
ce sont des anciennes galeries
d'exploitation des mines contenant
désormais de l'eau qui sont à l'origine
de ces affaissements reportage
jacqueline pozzi et patrice wucher la
vie qui quitte tout un pan de quartier
en moins d'une semaine dans la cité de
curel les déménagements organisée à la
hâte se sont achevées ce soir l'arrêté
préfectoral n'a pas laissé le choix aux
43 familles il faut fuir ce sol qui se
dérobe le péril est immédiat
vous rendez compte toute une rue
complète est emballé derrière sur
affreux
les familles sont relogées par les
pouvoirs publics en attendant de savoir
si leur maison est réparable ou
définitivement perdu la cause c'est la
mine le sous-sol du quartier est truffé
de galeries la fin de l'exploitation
décidé le pompage des eaux souterraines
a été stoppée résultat des galeries
noyer et quelques mois plus tard le
terrain ça fesse aujourd'hui on cherche
les responsables
on essaie de se défiler il existe la
filiale d'usinor lormines qui essaye de
ne pas payer ou de payer le moins
possible
donc à partir de ce moment là il faut
être ferme
il faut que les structures judiciaires
dise le droit
et puis poursuivre ça la réponse de
lormines l'exploitant minier un courrier
adressé à la préfecture qui réfute toute
responsabilité à moyeuvre lormines qui a
pourtant déjà été incriminés lors des
affaissements d'auboué il ya deux ans
aux bouées ou deux quartiers sont
entièrement condamné devant cette loi
des séries les autorités ont mené l
enquête et ont découvert que quinze
mille hectares présente des risques dans
le bassin
ce que l'on ne sait pas faire c'est
déterminer le moment où cet affaissement
va se produire ça peut se produire dans
une semaine dans un mois dans 10 ans ou
dans 100 ans et c'est une des
difficultés qu'il faut que l'on gère
c'est la durée
dans la commune de geof la population
est très dense et le risque
d'affaissement très important d'où cette
installation unique en france relié à
des capteurs dont le sol qui détecte
tout mouvement de terrain une manière de
faire de la prévention pour éviter
d'autres moyeuvre d'autres au bout et où
les affaissements auront déjà coûté 250
millions de francs
ça y est c'est fait le porte avions
nucléaire charles de gaulle a quitté ce
matin le port militaire de brest
direction du boulet qui sépare la rade
de la haute mer sceptre mortais retirait
le porte-avions ses premiers essais en
haute mer avait été repoussée pour cause
de météo capricieuse et puis c'est
officiel ce soir le gouvernement a
décidé de lancer la privatisation
partielle de la compagnie aérienne air
france en cédant plus de 20% au marché
et aux salariés plus de 32 millions
d'actions sur un total de 184 millions
actuellement détenue par l'état vont
être cédés si les conditions de marché
le permettent
l'opération de rapporter environ 4
milliards de francs à l'état les grandes
manoeuvres dans l'audiovisuel au tour du
groupe de communication pacte et vivendi
c'est à dire l'ancienne générale des
eaux et sa filiale canal+ sont
maintenant en position de force face à
tf1 dans la société pathé productrice de
films téléfilms c'est un peu compliqué
en matière boursière mais on aura bien
retenu que 25 bolloré qui a vendu ses
parts dans l'opération à récupérer 800
millions de francs alors pour y voir
plus clair explications de jean bernard
schmidt avec yann fronty
vous vous souvenez peut-être de ses
actualités film est signé pathé
et si aujourd'hui le groupe de jérôme
seydoux intéresse tout le monde c'est
parce qu'il fait 2 milliards de francs
de chiffre d'affaires gère 26 complexe
cinéma produit ou possède de nombreux
films et surtout contrôler 20% du
bouquet numérique canalsat et les
premiers actes décembre dernier vincent
bolloré qui vient de se dégager de tf1
part à la conquête de pathé il achète
près de 20% des actions deuxième acte
tf1 passe à l'offensive jeudi dernier
patrick le lay annonce détenir 9 % du
capital de pathé et n'entend visiblement
pas s'arrêter là
l'enjeu une position stratégique dans
l'un des premiers producteurs de cinéma
français troisième acte la contre
offensive devant la poussée de tf1
canal+ et viven dirait est entré dans
pâté pour défendre défendre d'abord
canalsatellite l'éviter comme canalsat
et les soit gêné par tf1 qui par
ailleurs les concurrence avec tps tps
l'autre programme satellite canal plus
et vit 20-10 rachète les parts de
vincent bolloré pour 3 milliards au
terme de cette guerre éclair ils
deviennent le deuxième actionnaire de
pâté avec 25% des actions résultats
pierre lescure pour canal+ et son allié
jean marie messier de vie vingt dix se
sont assurés un partenariat solide dans
le cinéma et le numérique
les actions pâté de vincent bolloré lui
ont rapporté une plus-value de 800
millions de francs
le grand perdant c'est tf1 qui a dépensé
plus d'un milliard de francs et qui ne
peut avec moins de 10% du capital rien
décidé chez pathé
la can le 33e marché international du
disque et de l'édition musicale s'est
ouvert le midem rassemble les grandes
sociétés de production et de
distribution ainsi que les labels
indépendants qui se livrent souvent une
bataille très vieille mais ils ont tous
en commun une inquiétude la voc de plus
en plus grande de la copie via les
ordinateurs des cd de musique
pour certains c'est du piratage et un
manque à gagner reportage daniel
wolfromm et bernard on flaire alors sur
internet pour pouvoir chercher des des
musiques
on est donc on les cherche au format mp3
compressés en fait il s'agit de
rechercher un serveur il y en a des
dizaines sur internet qui proposent des
listes de chansons comme celle ci on
enregistre ensuite le titre pour le
transférer sur son ordinateur et le
dupliquer sans perte de qualité sur un
seul disque
on peut ainsi gravé l'équivalent de 10
cd soit 200 titres
ce qui est bien tout ça qu'on peut on
peut écouter les chansons en même temps
qu on en cherche le transfert dure
environ un quart d'heure pour un seul
titre
maintenant je laisse j'ai plus besoin
d'être connecté sur internet je peux me
déconnecter c'est fini j'écoute j'écoute
le morceau quand je veux et si j'ai
envie je peux le mettre sur un cd à la
retraite du graveur et après je les
écoute sur ma chaîne je vais l'emmener
chez des amis pour l'écouter d'à côté
ont considéré que comme un pirate ou pas
non non non parce que disons que je fais
pas de commerces vraiment mais il y à
tous ceux qui en profitent pour revendre
leur copie grâce à ces graveurs de cd en
vente libre à partir de 2500 francs
alors vous pouvez lutter contre ça pas
de trois façons la première phase on a
les technologiques
c'est de convaincre les industriels par
des négociations ça ne sera pas facile
de limiter au moins une seule copie le
nombre de copies possible à partir d'un
cd vierges la deuxième deuxième moyen
d'avoir des rémunération pour la copie
privée
et puis la troisième chose c'est d'avoir
un droit éventuellement d'autorisation
diffusion numérique notamment sur
internet parce que sinon et bien
effectivement sans rémunération n'y a
pas d'investissement dans la création
donc ces systèmes qui va mourir de
lui-même pour les maisons de disques le
manque à gagner devient préoccupant le
quart du marché pourraient être perdus
dans les prochaines années si rien n'est
fait d'ici là
principale victime de ce commerce
parallèle les auteurs compositeurs jean
claude vannier a écrit des chansons pour
des dizaines d'artistes gainsbourg jonas
nougaro julien clerc je trouve que c'est
méprisant par rapport aux artistes et
aux compositeurs je trouve sympa très
élégant cette idée là que on peut servir
de de ce que les gens ont fait avec
coeur et en faire n'importe quoi ils
vont donner éventuellement grain gratos
cas sans payer pour convaincre les
jeunes de ne plus copié leurs morceaux
préférés la sacem qui gère les droits
d'auteur va lancer une campagne
d'information la tâche s'annonce plutôt
rude
vous achetez encore souvent des cd ou
pas maintenant a cédé de titres ça coûte
34 ans et la deuxième chanson elle est
toujours pourri à partir du moment où il
ya plus d'argent dans le système
le 3è 4è disent que tu aimes bien il
sortira plus on vous copier un
enregistrement vous avez exactement la
même chose que cela discussions
s'éternisent et ne convainc personne
monsieur forest vous avez du boulot
ceci annonce en fait le bouleversement
du droit des auteurs et des créateurs
avec en toile de fond une révolution
dans l'édition musicale
l'ancien dirigeant du club de football
de bordeaux monsieur claude bez est mort
beaucoup ce soir lui rendent hommage
ainsi michel platini jean marc ferreri
guy roux ou encore bernard tapie claude
bez avait présidé de façon parfois
spectaculaire les girondins de bordeaux
de 1974 à 1990 commentaires david
béziers à bordeaux claude bez c'est
l'homme des coups d'éclat l'expert
comptable truculent devenu président du
club des girondins de bordeaux pour le
meilleur
l'équipe des tigana et des giresse qui
remporte le doublé coupe de
france-championnat en 87 contre la
presse
autre coup d'éclat l'autre face de
claude bez car en 90 les affaires ont
débuté
claude bez et mise en examen pour
escroquerie dans la sphère des girondins
le président est accusé notamment de
fausses factures dans la rénovation du
somptueux centre d'entraînement du
haillan
le procès de l'organisation des matches
devaient lui s'ouvrir le 22 février
prochain
reste une image le moustachu bon vivant
et sa cadillac tennis aux internationaux
d'australie la nuit dernière amélie
mauresmo s'est qualifiée pour les demi
finales la française actuellement 29e
joueuse mondiale affrontera la numéro 1
du moment l'américaine lindsay davenport
amélie mauresmo
c'est une athlète solide des subtiles
écrivait ce matin notamment notre
confrère l'équipe
commentaires alexandre kara amélie
mauresmo vous l'aurez compris est une
jeune femme de caractère
la belge dominique van roost ne vous
dira pas le contraire de ce match je
l'espérais beaucoup mais certainement
pas ça rapide et puissant c'est le
service d'amélie mauresmo
il dépasse souvent les 170 km/heure ses
larmes qui a permis à la française de
s'imposer en une heure et demie tout
juste 6 3 7 6 vendre ou hst la 11e
mondiale est dehors
voilà amélie mauresmo 29e parmi les
meilleurs qualifiés pour la demi finale
d'un tournoi du grand chelem
c'est son meilleur résultat chez les
grands une victoire sans complexe est
rationnée de mal de matches au premier
tour on est pas mal on arrivait donc
chose de pierre voit donc je me suis
m'écoute tu fonces c'est un bonus je
dirais de ne pouvoir jouer les matchs
restants
donc je joue ma chance à fond et en
riant tout en étant la chaîne la
réussite d'amélie mauresmo
ce n'est pas une surprise août 96 elle a
16 ans et demi elle remporte le tournoi
de roland garros chez les juniors 96 la
belle année pour maurice mais
victorieuse à wimbledon elle devient
championne du monde juniors la victoire
elle adore ça à 19 ans mauresmo n'est
pas vraiment précoce surtout si l'on en
juge par l'âge des jeunes gloires du
tennis féminin mais en deux ans elle a
progressé à son rythme gagnant
régulièrement en puissance comme en
pétrole
en demi-finale la française rencontrera
lindsay davenport l'américaine numéro un
mondial l'an dernier maurice moins
réussi l'exploit battre davenport
c'était lors de l'open d'allemagne
c'est dire si elle a la rage de vaincre
c'est dire si désormais tout est
possible
et puis marie pierre sur un quart de
finale la nuit prochaine contre martina
hingis
enfin en boxe hier soir le français jean
baptiste mendy a conservé son titre
mondial des poids légers face à
l'argentin cicorel sereinement la fin de
cette émission je vous rappelle deux
informations que nous avons développées
tout d'abord concernant la colombie le
tremblement de terre au centre ouest de
la colombie la nuit dernière premiers
bilans officieux notamment la vie
d'arméniens fait état de plus de mille
morts et puis cette information
concernant le dopage dans le cyclisme
selon un premier pré-rapport la moitié
des coureurs cyclistes français pour
être utilisé des produits dopants et
leur santé en or et été et en serait
fragilisée
en quelques secondes la météo avec
nathalie rihouet n'oubliez pas 22h40
place de la république on reviendra sur
le problème de délinquance avec gilles
schneider yamina benguigui et puis à 0
heures 20 heures journal de la nuit
présentée par laurence ostolaza suivi du
cercle de philippe le fait à demain 20h
bonsoir merci